Speaker 1: All right, let's go back to the
Dischord Lines and hear from some more folks
you can find The David Pakman Show discord
at David Pakman dot com slash discord, of
course.
Why don't we talk to.
Oh, you know what?
You know who's on New Grundler from California
is here, a crossover caller from the majority
report and other shows that some may be aware
with, aware of knew what is going on.
Speaker 6: Hello, David.
Hello.
So I'm not going to bring up that thing you
told me not to bring up before you started
recording.
OK.
Let me begin by not bringing that up.
All right, so I let you know, as you've mentioned,
I've been getting radicalized over at Friends
of the Set the majority report with Sam Theater.
Mm hmm.
And they have assessed that the friendly language
of Democratic Party leadership like Biden
and Pelosi towards Republicans is a significant
part of what Republicans gain.
Seats in the House recently saying things
like, we need Republicans, Republicans to
come around after Trump has gone, etc. and,
you know, I've had enough.
I think it's time for the Democratic Party
to start trash talking these clowns.
You see what I mean by radicalization, but
anyways, sure, let's not forget that the Trump
admin didn't want to do stimulus checks at
first, calling them bailouts of Democrat run
cities.
Right.
So I asked, you know, is it time or is it
risky?
Because I guess margin would be even less
cooperative.
Speaker 1: I don't know that I understand
the question is the question about the rhetoric
towards Republicans or the discussions within
Democrats
Speaker 6: know the rhetoric, rhetoric toward
Republicans.
I should Democratic politicians start, you
know, kind of just abandoning.
You know, this kind of.
Friendly attitude towards bipartisanship.
Speaker 1: Yeah, OK, I understand.
OK, so this is a good question.
Listen, here's here's my thought on this.
And I even talked about this earlier in the
week to to some extent, I think it's good
to say you would rather get something done
with Republicans than without them.
I think that that's a great thing to say.
Why not?
Right.
Let's if we can if we can do something with
Republicans without compromising our values,
let's do it with Republicans.
I think it's great to involve Republicans
in the conversation when I read that Joe Biden
has had this or that Republican at the White
House and they talked about this and they
talked about that's fantastic.
But you've got to know when to cut it off.
And so now we have reports, for example, that
the negotiations with Biden and Republicans
on the infrastructure bill are now done because
Republicans, you know, Biden sliced a trillion
dollars off and Republicans came up one hundred
and fifty billion.
It's like, come on, guys, that's not going
to go anywhere.
So you just cut it off.
And the problem for Democrats is twofold.
Number one, now there's like a moderate group
of Democrats and Republicans negotiating the
infrastructure bill.
I don't know that something that gets negotiated
by moderate Democrats and Republicans actually
get 60 votes in the Senate.
I think you end up if you're on the on the
Democratic side, your only option will end
up being budget reconciliation.
And that's if you can get 50 votes.
And then it becomes a matter of can you convince
Joe Manchin, can you convince Kirsten cinema?
So I don't have a problem with the talk of
bipartisanship.
I don't have a problem with negotiations.
I don't have a problem with involving Republicans.
But at a certain point, you have to cut it
off and you have to say we're doing it our
way and we're just going to do it.
The problem is, if you only have forty nine
votes in the Senate, then you can't do it.
And that's where Joe Manchin gets all of his
power from.
Speaker 6: Yeah, it's of bleak.
Speaker 1: It's bleak.
I'm not going to lie, but listen, we still
have Meems, right?
We at least have that.
Speaker 6: We do, that's true.
I should get started on some of those, too,
I have some ideas, please, please.
Speaker 1: I think that that would bring a
nice positive energy to the show.
Speaker 6: All right.
You know what that means?
I am waiting for, though, is when the elections
get close and.
That means last year of something important
and then it goes after you think as a matter
we need to get out and vote right about
Speaker 1: we're going to get back to that.
We're going to get back to that.
All right.
Thank you for
the call, my friend.
Speaker 6: Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
There we go.
New wrangler there